my name is guna geros i am a developer
advocate at amazon web services and
in the the last decade the movement
towards cicd has been
really transformational for getting
value out to customers quickly
but in recent years there's been new
processes tooling towards using
configuration post deployment in the
form of feature flags operational config
and other runtime configuration so in
this session we'll look at how to
continually adjusting configuration to
update and tune your code in production
how that is a powerful fast and safe way
to deploy value to customers and we're
going to look at how amazon uses
continuous configuration tools at scale
to move fast
and ensure maximum availability of
services
so
there we go all right so in the early
days of amazon.com making changes to the
e-commerce code codebase was complex it
was slow and it was fraught with danger
so
only a single change would require a
complete redeploy of a single monolithic
executable and the executable in
question it was over one gigabyte in
size and it took over a day to compile
so there was so much time between making
a change in the code base and then
seeing the impact in production that it
was really difficult to correlate the
two
so over the years as amazon scaled and
grew this slow software deploy
deployment process was really a
bottleneck that limited the pace of
which we could deliver features and
application improvements for customers
so to solve this
amazon broke down that model it
moving towards a service service
oriented design so this empowered the
teams to ship features faster and more
frequently
and it also reduced the blast radius of
changes to all of the different
individual services so with this shift
of
ownership came the need for individual
teams to manage the deployment and
operation of their services resulting in
the creation of many streamlined
processes and procedures similar to the
cicd pipelines we use today so let's
just take a quick look at cicd
so continuous integration as i think
many of you know is a software
development practice where developers
regularly merge their code changes into
a central repository
after which automated builds and tests
are run so continuous integration most
often refers to the build or integration
stage of the software release process
and it entails both both an automation
component
and it could be the build service and a
cultural component learning to integrate
frequently and the key goals of
continuous integration are to find and
address bugs quicker improve software
quality and then reduce the time it
takes to validate and release new
software
updates so why was continuous
integration needed well in the past
developers on a team they they might
work in isolation for an extended period
of time and only merge their changes to
the master branch once the work was
completed
and this made merging code changes
difficult and really time consuming so
it also resulted in bugs accumulating
for a long time without correction
and these factors made it harder to
deliver updates to customers quickly
so continuous integration works with
developers frequently commit to a shared
repository using git for instance and
prior to each commit the developers use
to run local unit tests under code as an
extra verification layer before
integrating so a continuous integration
service automatically then builds and
runs unit tests on the new code changes
to immediate immediately surface any
errors
then we have continuous deployment and
continuous delivery and those are
software development practices where
code changes are then automatically
prepared for rare release to production
so
as a pillar of modern application
development continuous delivery and
continuous deployment expands upon
continuous integration by deploying all
of these code changes to a testing
environment and or a production
environment after the build stage so
when properly implemented the developers
will always have a deployment ready
build artifact that has passed through a
standardized test process so continuous
delivery and deployment lets developers
automate testing beyond just unit tests
so they can verify application updates
across multiple dimensions before
deploying to customers
and these tests might include ui testing
load testing integration testing
api reliability testing and so on and so
on so it helps developers more
thoroughly validate updates and
preemptively discover
issues and
um
it then
sorry
with continuous
delivery every code change is built
tested and then pushed to a
non-production testing or staging
environment and there can be multiple
parallel test stages before production
deployment and the difference between
continuous delivery and continuous
deployment is the presence of a manual
improvement to update to production with
continuous deployment production
happens automatically without this
explicit approval
so
this is a very simplified
look at stages of of software release
the process for that
so
we start off with the source stage and
often that's the last time that the
developers see their code they then put
their code into remote repositories for
code reviews and so
then we have the build stage where we'll
do unit tests reading getting our
artifacts
and then we'll deploy it into multiple
stages and then into production and
we're always deploying the same artifact
into all of our environments so in the
testing stage we're going to try
integration test performance tests and
so on everything we need to make sure
that the application is ready to go to
production
and then we go into production we want
to deploy with the least amount of
downtime possible
so looking at this from
what we looked at previously well this
is basically the continuous integration
phase
we then have the continuous delivery
cycle with that manual improvement
and then we have continuous deployment
and this is where amazon then moved into
having processes that were similar to
this
but then
release is just the start of a software
project so
at this point configuration was still
managed directly in the application's
code base making all of the changes very
slow and still requiring
a service to be redeployed or restarted
to adopt the new configuration so it was
quite clear at amazon that while ci cd
practices and technologies solved for
many of the deployment challenges i
explained early on
taking hours to do deployments there was
still a lack of ability to modify
application behavior quickly and
especially in response to dynamic live
environments so
that capability is necessary to achieve
that availability requirement for a
system like amazon.com
so
how about a new way of thinking of this
so we start off with continuous
integration and we then add on with
continuous delivery or continuous
deployment
but then something new continuous
configuration
and continuous configuration then
enables software teams to have dials and
switches that allows them to change the
runtime behavior of their application
so just as amazon evolved external
developers have been using application
configuration to change how their
software behaves for quite a long time
but generally this configuration is
static in nature and companies remain
stuck using antiquated techniques that
don't really allow them to best serve
their customers so the configuration is
loaded as an application initialized and
then remains the same until the app
restarts alternatively some customers
have hacked together ways to pull these
configuration details from other places
be it amazon s3 or a database entry
somewhere and while this can work for
some
these custom solution implementations
often face constraints around latency
scalability ease of use and a lot more
so true dynamic configuration is
different the source of the
configuration truth it lives in an
independent configuration management
system and it's pulled by the consuming
application
so these are configuration values that
an engineer anticipates will need to be
changed easily in the future or might
vary according to specific system
conditions even if they don't know
exactly when that will be
and these values often fall into two
groups
those that modify operational behavior
of an application such as throttling
limits connection limits or logging
verbosity and those that control fac
feature access control and that includes
feature flags a b testing and user allow
or deny lists so
continuous configuration is the process
of updating these dynamic configuration
values during runtime all without
deploying
new code or restarting the app and it's
also the practice of rolling out these
changes in a controlled way using a
deployment strategy
across your application fleet
so
if we start off with ci cd and we have
those practices in place
we now want to move to ci
cc for continuous configuration
so let's look at some different use
cases for continuous configuration
well a very common one is what's called
feature flags so
code is deployed to production but it's
hidden behind the feature flag
configuration
so
once a feature is ready it can then be
released to small cohorts first for
instance internal users
and
app and new feature performance is
measured to understand the impact of new
features
and features are slowly rolled out to
more users over time and if something
goes wrong teams can then immediately
roll back features that they have
changed
or released with the help of continuous
configuration and all of this without a
restart or without code changes so a
very common use case for this capability
with feature flags is delivering an
application change for an event
occurring at a precise time where a
configuration change in a cc or
continuous configuration system it's
much smaller quicker and more reliable
than trying to relaunch an entire
application or rely on say a dns
switchover
so an example a customer who produces a
tv show could use
a continuous configuration system to
manage audience participation so that
voting user interfaces can be displayed
inside of mobile applications
at the very moment that the tv host
announced that voting is now open
on the latest reality show and closed
for all users as soon as the period has
completed next we have what's called
operational flags
so app teams and operational teams they
coordinate ahead of time to building
throttling values into configuration
and as environmental factors change in
your production environments the
operational team can then dial this
throttling up and down
so an example of this is if cpu alarms
go off due to traffic spikes the
operational team can then travel down
non-essential background tasks to handle
the spikes in your production
environment and to handle these traffic
spikes
and once again all of this done without
any restarts or without any code changes
needing to be deployed
then we have what's called security
flags so
also here app application teams and
operational teams that can coordinate
ahead of time to build in flags to
control logging verbosity
so during a suspected production in the
incident teams can then dynamically
increase the verbosity of data collected
about for instance a suspected bad actor
and teams are able to increase logging
until the incident is over then
returning to the normal levels
and once again with continuous
configuration
everything is done without the restart
or without any code changes
so there are some dangers of continuous
configurations because just like in code
we can have typos and it can cause
outages and if a config is rolled out
too quickly it can have a large blast
radius
so having the option to be able to roll
back confidently is really critical for
using continuous configuration in a safe
way and think about how we work with
cicd today if there are issues in our
tests or in our deployments we do a
robomac and the same applies for cc
continuous configuration
and thinking about these use cases that
i just mentioned feature flags
operational flags and security flags
you might think that you could simply
use a database switch or some in-memory
flag to solve these problems
but our experience at aws and at amazon
is that writing configuration systems is
complicated particularly at scale so
one of those things we learned by in
analyzing our internal correction of
errors coes over the last years are that
configuration changes cause outages at
about the same rate as code changes so
when it comes to resolving outages
manual configuration changes are being
made when stress levels are high further
increasing the risk of errors in changes
or attempted rollbacks so in the moment
where changes are the most critical
validation systems and guardrails help
you give that surgical precision when
your hand probably is the most shakiest
so at aws we use something called app
config when we launch launch services
when a new service is in development it
will often be in production before it's
actually released and internal users
some partners and customers are granted
access to provide feedback or produce
launch materials
so we add these users via an allow list
managed by a continuous configuration
system
when the service is launched such as
following an announcement at for
instance a reinvent coming up in a
couple of weeks we changed the
configuration so the service is
available to all accounts and not just
those on the allow list
and then as new features enter preview
it's significantly easier to manage a
single production deployment with an
allow list for beta users compa compared
to managing a separate stable data build
of the application concurrently
so
aws app.config which was launched
publicly in 2019 for all aws customers
to use but we've used internally since
2016.
and today
in all of amazon it is used by over 4
000 different service teams
and it makes configuration changes safe
and quick to make and it also allows us
to make updates at scale think about
that
service release example i just talked
about where we're able to make these
changes to roll out an entirely new aws
service to all of our million customers
around the world
and this is really what allows us to use
that practice ci cd
cc
and
one of the features with app.config is
what's called validators which then
allows us to prevent errors with the
help of these validators and they are
um they allow any syntactic or semantic
check to be made before the
configuration is deployed and then
allows us to prevent those errors as i
mentioned it as the same with code it's
easy to make
typos but using validators help us to
avoid those so
even the smallest configuration change
can of course cause a massive outage so
it's important to validate the
configuration
and many of the configuration changes
they're made
when stress levels are high just when we
need to launch something at the top of a
keynote for instance
and many engineers or product managers
they might need some type of baby
proofing when they want to do those
changes
and then another one is
the ability to limit blast radius with
the help of monitoring and roll back so
with app config and continuous
configuration it allows us to monitor
and then do auto roll back allow us to
have this customer control bake time
where we're monitoring the deployment to
make sure that it actually actually
works as intended
and then if something happens we can do
an automatic rollback when an alarm is
triggered and then that limits our last
radius
so um configuration should have
monitoring tools of course just in the
same way as with our code
and
if a configuration change needs to be
rolled back it should be immediately
and any application
which really has configuration is a use
case for aws app config and this could
be allow lists and it could be block
lists it can be any type of private apis
for instance where you want to make
changes to the url for an api and where
you want to roll out that change to your
application or it might be for uris for
resources something that
can change quite regularly in our
experience and in the way that we build
systems
and using
continuous configuration with for
instance app config is great for av
testing to be able to roll out changes
to smaller
groups and allow them to test something
and it also helps us when we're
promoting configuration moving from that
development stage into our quality
assurance stage and then finally into
production
and a quite common use case is the
verbosity of logging as i mentioned
before for instance when we want to
increase logging when there is a
security incident or if there are any
other types of instance we can quickly
make those changes in our applications
using continuous configuration
and the final one that i've mentioned
several times now is feature flags
that's probably one of the most common
use cases for continuous configuration
so i want to show you a quick example of
how continuous configuration works for
us by having a look at app.config
so switching over to
a live demo now i want you all to cross
your fingers and let's hope that our
demo gods are with us so this is the aws
console some of you might be familiar
with it i'm gonna look at my monitor
next to the camera now so sorry if i'm
looking away
and i've set up a simple application
demo which is basically a serverless api
serverless api that just returns a value
to make it as simple as possible
but
the use cases they are well they are a
million different use cases for this so
think about how you could implement that
in whatever system you're building
i'm gonna switch to
vs code
and this api is built as a serverless
api so i'm using a api gateway to then
for us to be able to call that api and
it is backed by one single aws lambda
function and it's a basic hello world
example so
this is
the app
go right simple handler that just
returns hello from lambda
let's check to make sure that it
actually works
calling that url
and yeah it's
returning hello from them cool
but i want to use continuous
configuration with the help of app
config to then change the behavior of my
application and i'm doing that in a very
simple way first off let's have a look
at the template for my application i'm
building this using infrastructure as
code with the help of aws sam our
serverless framework for
for building serverless applications and
in that i've defined my
serverless function my aws lambda
function
and calling out the handler that is
where the code is
and then i'm adding aws app config to
this and i'm doing that with the help of
something called lambda extensions so it
is basically adding what's called a
layer to my application which then
contains all of that logic for
fetching the configuration which makes
it easy for me so adding that layer
and then i've just added a policy to be
able to fetch it that means that my
lambda function is allowed to fetch that
configuration
and
then in the actual lambda function the
the application code i'm making just an
a simple function that's calling that
lambda layer which is then hosted on
localhost on that lambda function
and fetching
and using a simple http called fetching
the url for my configuration
when that configuration is received i
can then use that in my handler so let's
have a quick look at what the
configuration looks like
in app config i've created uh what's
called the configuration profile
which is my config and this is
simple example uh json containing just
two items first off
if it's enabled or not
let's start with version one
and in this case it is set to enabled
false
and then i have another one to set a
message option and then i'm using this
in my lambda function
so first off
i'm checking is
my
option enabled or not
if it's not enabled it should return
this message hello from lambda which was
the one we saw when we simply looked at
that api
if it is enabled we should instead
return hello from and then the message
option from that configuration
so set it several times
super simple example of how we can use
this but
this is basically a feature flag true or
false if this feature should be enabled
then we have some additional parameters
in this case the message option
so
checking my api again it's working
let's then make a change to this so
creating a new version of my
configuration
setting it to true
and let's set the message option to
india
creating that new version
version 3 now exists
and i can then deploy this into my
production environment in this case so
starting a new deployment
choosing version three
and then i can choose the deployment
strategy and the deployment strategy is
basically how will this be rolled out
and there are different um preset com
deployment strategies available here you
can create your own what's fitting for
you and and it's basically how will you
roll out this configuration change it
might be that you want to do it
in a linear way in an exponential way
and you want to do it to a small subset
first and then roll out to the rest and
so on and you can set this up and and
use it any way you wish
and besides that deployment and the time
it takes to deploy you also are able to
set what's called a bake time i
mentioned that earlier as well and the
bake time it's the time after deployment
that the deployment will be monitored
for any errors and if errors happen we
are able to then roll back
so
first off i'm just going to make this
in demo mode meaning that the deployment
time is zero minutes and bake time is
zero minutes so it should switch over
straight away
starting the deployment
and it's already complete since it was
zero minutes so now if i switch back to
my api
it has changed to hello from a agile
india
and so far using that well you might
once again think well i can do that
using environment variables or i can do
it using
a database change or something like that
but when we start using these features
like rolling out deployments and using
the different deployment
strategies
that's when a configuration system like
app config really makes sense so let's
do it again
and this time i want to show you that
for my environment i have an alarm set
up
and the alarm in this case is simple
cloud watch alarm which then
exists here
and it basically checks for errors and
this could be any alarm think about
what's important for you it could be
metric alarms it could be
well a systematic alarm or it could be
perhaps a more
business metric alarm that makes sense
for instance um an e-commerce site well
the number of purchases per second or
minute is perhaps a very important
metric for you so rolling out the
feature maybe that's what you should
check are people still
purchasing with the same frequencies as
before that configuration change
right but in this case it's just
checking my lambda function for errors
and if it
receives an error it will then
go into the alarm states
all right so
back to app config
and let's then
start a new deployment
let's roll back to
my
first version
version one
and now i'm instead going to use a
different deployment strategy still a
quick one
also for test demo this one has a one
minute deployment time and then a one
minute break time
so it uses a linear growth type so it
will start with 50 of users will receive
this new version and then the other 50
so basically after 30 seconds 50 will
have it after another 30 seconds
everyone will have this new version
so let's start that deployment and
remember now that we have that
monitoring in place
all right
so far we're still at the old version
and this is the part of the demo where
i can just wait for the deployment to
happen
and hopefully there aren't any errors so
this won't roll back
30 seconds is a long time while doing
demo so 50 is complete
so
we should probably get
version one
come on
100
complete
oops
there is a bit of a caching mechanism in
that
app config extension that i'm using
there we go so now it switched back to
version one hello from lambda so now a
final example of this let's deploy this
new version once again
as soon as our bake time is over and now
i'm gonna trigger that alarm and to make
sure that
it actually works the way that i told
you
so wait for the bake time to finish
and since
i can't really create an error in my
application in an easy way what i'm
going to do is to use the
use the aws cli
find that window and switch it there
and a simple cli command which allows me
to then
set this
i have too many windows so need to just
copy that command
there we go
all right hopefully it's done now
one minute still not over
there we go now it's complete
so
starting the final phase
switching back to version three meaning
that it will enable
that feature flag and it will change to
agile in the item
but this time i'm going to trigger the
alarm so let's start the deployment and
let's
imagine that this is my very important
business website where we're then
monitoring that just make sure that
things work as intended
starting the deployment
it's now going to start deploying
and i'm going to make use of the aws cli
to set the alarm state for my alarm
into the alarm
state value
bang checking cloud watch
it is now in the alarm state
something went wrong with my application
and
did i not use the right
alarm
there we go all right
we can now see that the deployment was
stopped due to a cloud watch alarm
something went wrong with my application
so it's going to roll back that
configuration change and it does that
pretty much straight away as soon as the
alarm is picked up by app config in this
case so rolling back to
hello from lambda which was our version
one
so very quick example of how we can use
it this was using a
super simple serverless api using api
gateway and a lambda function but you
can use this with ec2 you can use it
with with basically any compute platform
and you can roll out these configuration
changes in an easy way
and let me
switch it back here all right so
looking forward a bit then
in in much the way that cicd reduced the
fear of deployment continuous
configuration reduces the fear of
changing configuration so by exercising
this capability regularly we build
confidence and can start to enable
automation
and the systems like app config builds
in this automation so
as you saw i create a cloudwatch alarm
that performs this health check in the
application and you can have app config
monitor that and then when the alarm
went into the alarm state well it will
then roll back that deployment
and for me i think this is really where
continuous configuration starts to
change the way that we're able to
operate it makes it really easy and safe
to change configuration and
um
these are big words but we're actually
able to democratize configuration
because you don't have to be a software
engineer to make changes to applications
it can
it's really a benefit that
these continuous configuration systems
and that practice it means that pretty
much anyone with the
protective guard rails in place
can then self-serve and make changes in
application behavior it can be a
junioring engineer to scale up the
number of database connections it can be
a product manager that wants to add
customers to a beta service for instance
or maybe even the ux designer that wants
to modify an a b tests
uh cohort split
so
democratizing of ownership helps to
remove this operational
um engineers as a bottleneck for changes
in production environments
and we have this phase we move from
configuring to validating and we then
deploy this and we monitor that
deployment
so
some additional resources if you want to
check out aws app config and
check some documentation for that it's
available on screen and there's also a
great blog post on continuous
configuration written by
our good friend and cto werner vogels
that's also available
with that i want to thank you all for
watching we've looked at how to
continually adjust configuration to
update and tune your code in production
and how that is a powerful fast and and
safe way to deploy value to customers if
you have any questions besides what
might be in the q a do reach out to me
on twitter at you
as shown on screen or happy to connect
on linkedin as well
so thank you very much for watching